All right. Welcome to
the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited
speaker, let's go over some
rules as usual. First of all,
please mute yourself during the
talk. If you have immediate
questions, you're welcome to
unmute and ask. Otherwise,
please use the chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in the q&a session
at the end. Second, today's
seminar is open to external
audience. So no classified
discussion is allowed annually,
the talk will be recorded and
uploaded to our YouTube channel.
So now let me introduce our
speaker. It is an honor to your
host, Alvaro  Coutinho, who is a
professor in civil engineering
and the CO coordinator of the
interdisciplinary area of
computational engineering and
science at COPPE The Alberto
Luiz Coimbra Institute for
Graduate Studies and Research in
Engineering in the Federal
University of Rio de Janeiro in
Brazil. He got his doctoral
degree in the same school in
1987. He is a recipient of an
IBM faculty Partnership Award in
2001. The JT is the audit and
faculty fellowship at UT Austin
in 2004. The Giulio Massarani
Academic award at COPPE in 2007
and the International
Association of competition
mechanics Fellow award in 2012.
Professor Coutinho has organized
national and international
conferences, training workshops
and short courses serving in
scientific committees of many
conferences, including the
Supercomputing Conference design
conference on parallel
processing file MS in flow
clubrooms, the US National
Congress on competition
mechanics and a road Congress on
computational mechanics. He
serves on the executive
committee of the International
Association of the computational
mechanics and in the Brazilian
association for computational
methods in engineering. He is a
member of the editorial board of
international journal of
numerical methods in engineering
and computational methods in
applied mechanics and
engineering. And on the effort
advisory board of the
International Journal of
numerical methods and fluids, he
coordinate over 80 industrial
projects, directed further three
PhD thesis and 47, Master of
Science dissertations. He is
author of 136 peer reviewed
journal papers and over 450
conference papers. He was the PI
of the Brasilia project HPC for
E high performance computing for
energy from 2017 2000 to 2020.
He is currently the PI of the
informatics network of in
artificial intelligence for
renewable energy and climate
change, supported by the real
the general state agency for
research. Today, he will talk
about enhancing data driven
workflows for complex
simulations, please enjoy the
wonderful talk. Now without
further ado, let me hand it over
to everyone.
Okay, thanks, Tony. For the long
introduction, you could really
shorten just by say I still play
beach volleyball. Okay. Well,
it's a pleasure to be here
today. And well, you'll see my
screen and I'm glad to share
with you our view on how to
enhance data driven workflow for
complex simulations. The agenda
for today is, well, we'll do a
quick review on the simulation
workflow. Then we're going to
talk about your see how
Institute of Israel diseases
fits within and how we do
computational steering. And then
the first first question we're
going to address in this talk as
have snapshot based data driven
computations fit within this
simulation workflow within stata
visualization, then we're going
to see a lot of case studies
using basically a dynamic mode
decomposition. Okay. So there's
a lot of questions, we'll see.
First, we're gonna ask
ourselves, what would happen if
it compressed the snapshots?
What we do if the snapshots are
not in the same space, for
instance, coming from Adaptive
mesh refinement and cortical
computations? And then I'm going
to discuss how can we makes the
Institute of visualization
workflow, what is streaming DMD?
Is it good for anything and then
I let's, let's discuss this. And
in the end, if I have time, I
will address a particular more
theoretical issue on the end,
should we do it couple or
uncouple and of course So we
will open for a q&a session in
the end. All right. Here Here
you see the basically a
simulation workflow. It starts
with some pre processing various
select parameters, like at an
ECL time step, the time
interval, set tolerance, and
pick up the solvers. And set up
in all the setup for the
adaptive mesh refinement in
courses, simulation, etc, then
stop time stepping. So while
you're not reach your timing,
maximum time interval, your
assembly and sold nonlinear
equations, your adaptive mesh
and the time step, you're
updating your solution. And then
if, if it's time to save data on
this, when required, update for
time step and move on. In the
end, you have a lot of data in
the disk, your post processing,
you do the post process,
basically visualize the data and
extract relevant quantities of
interest. Well Is that a
assembly in solving linear
linear equations by some Newton
like method is where you will
spend most of your computer
time. Innovate Step B.
Guarantees accuracy in in space
and time. And step D is where
you do IO to persistent storage.
And the right you'll see some
solutions, you know, some
simulations coming from our
group. Let's see that beautiful
one here on the top is a
solution of a non local phase
field model with Phoenix. And on
the right you can see a
timestamp via for order of
magnitude adaptive time step
Brian for you know several
orders of magnitude and below
the simulation for a droplet
impact using live mesh with
adaptive mesh refinement and
coursing. And you can see you
know, that showing the mesh
adaptivity. Well, many years
ago, this basically workflow
that still is still valid. In
this paper here in supercomputer
in 2010, they realized that the
optimal complexity of this
workflow is order of n to the
power four over three or n is
your total number of your
unknowns is easy to realize. Now
let's think that you have n over
three acute let's say within
over three unknowns in each of
the parties and directions and
you do a implicit time step with
a number of time steps of order
of n if you get everything
together you'll get this n to
the power of four three is
optimal in there is only optimal
if you solve your linearized
equations without an algorithm
it is linear scale is linearly
on time which is hardly to
achieve more or less we what we
see here is the only way to
improve this is diminishing the
number of points in space and
time okay. But there remains the
IO in persistent storage and
digitalization in getting
insight from your computations
alright. So, how does this
workflow becomes been put in
place in situ visualization,
utilization results of running
simulations instead of users
this is basically do the
visualization without the need
to copy data to a storage
device. Of course, it reduces
the amount of data and adds to
reducing traffic IO and volume.
And you can think that you can
access more data. For instance,
if you are writing to the disk,
at this interval, when doing
signal processing, you can do
can do more intervals. More than
that, people realize that we
can, we can do in real time the
simulation exploration and the
steering. Of course, it reduces
lattice latency to the first
result and avoid large scale
post processing. So the
traditional workflow we have the
simulator code, dump everything
to the disk and do the
visualization later. With this.
Now we write an adapter for this
powerful catalyst which is our
our choice for instant
visualization infrastructure is
not the only one. And you can
then produce you Using some
scripts, visualization in
runtime, new applications you
see in this yellow box in the
bottle are two new applications
are from the group coming from
the Kansas and Colorado border
that are so cool. They do, you
know, they, they go beyond an
enabling you to change your
let's say, change your your,
your domain during the
simulations using using this in
SQL tools. And also merge couple
in this is in situ, which
simulation workflow and the
machine learning workflow.
They're so cool, I really
appreciate that so much. And I
encourage you to read this. So
how it works basically in more
detail. The same the workflow
with instead of visualization
and is theory. Here, we build
that on top of lib mesh, you set
up the adaptive mesh refinement
of courses set up, start the
simulation setup, and then you
start looping time loop.
You know, as a couple months
physics solver, you do the fluid
solver, you do the transfer
equation, here we are. This was
specialized for sediment
transport, you're gonna see the
application in a moment. And do
we need an adaptive mesh
refinement, we do the writer and
then we move to the catalyst
adapter, call that catalyst
adapter, and those tracks from
the python script and generating
PNG files for ViSalus visual
visualization in certain what we
also do with this tool called
the F analyzer. The details are
in this yellow box in the in
below in the slide is that we
also gather other data that
allows us to interact with a lot
of parameters. And during the
simulation at the runtime, we we
annotated some data in the
database and then we query this
database if needed and changing
everything in the runtime more
or less, we can see this box
here that we are annotated
Nalina tolerances, time steps in
and some data needed for
controlling adaptive mesh
refinement and of course, inland
mesh. Alright, how it works,
okay, this is a simulation
sediment ran up and channel this
is a big channel. And this is
you know, visualization
generated in situ is a highly
turbulent flow with several can
see Reynolds number here is
5000. And is interesting that we
have some experimental data. And
the black curve corresponding to
the adaptive mesh refinement and
coursing simulation that you can
see on the right for a longer
time and see in this detail here
is adaptive mesh for this
configuration. So how
competition is steering walks.
Right. So we are some user
interacting with the code series
with when it's running. And then
that certain point at that time
step, the user decide that.
Let's relax some tolerances here
and see what happens. And then
he can do it in runtime, and
changing this tolerances and
also adapt more adaptive mesh
refinement tolerances, and see
if there's okay. And the
simulation progresses. Well, the
air in what we see here is a
huge saving in computer time.
And we can control this is
runtime, I mean essence,
everything is annotated in the
database that we're aware we can
query and interact with many
parameters in runtime. So this
is basically a simulation
workflow, where instead of
utilization and steering, all
this immediate image that you've
seen, they have been produced by
the Institute of visualization
capabilities. Right. So now can
with the data driven registered
order model, as I said before, I
will restrain myself to talk
about DMD. But if I'm, if I
succeed in my presentation,
you're gonna see that several of
those more computational
computer science thinks can be
applied to other ways of
building reduced order models.
Well, DMV needs observation for
a nonlinear problem at hand. And
this observation often comes
from snapshots of a large
parallel simulation with a
workflow just like the one we
have discussed. Snapshots are
written to disk, due to the gap
between computing and IO spin,
as Snapchat generation can
become a bottleneck,
particularly for large
simulation DMD as any several
other reducer otter models,
builds the reducer of a model,
of course, from a single value
decomposition of the snapshot
matrix. So we ask ourselves, and
you can see, then in the yellow
box here, the paper that we will
be building one of the paper
we're going to be building my
talk today, we ask ourselves
those good things in red here.
What happens if we compress the
snapshots to the minute IO. And
also, what happens when we merge
DMD with the simulation workflow
with incentivization and
steering? Those are the two
things we will address in a
minute, the two next things I
will address in this talk. Okay,
so this picture here is to try
to give you an idea how this
workflow will be merged, we have
the offline phase in HPC
machine, this is a simulation
with a live mesh and a finite
element simulation. And then we
have a two branches, this tender
branch where you dump everything
to the disk, but now with maybe
lossless and lossy data
compression, using one I will
come back to this one using one
floating point compressor. And
then we have a compressor
snapshot that has to be
decompressed. To be so
condemned, it can walk. And the
other hand, you have here the
institutionalization. In our
framework and running together,
we are the simulation that you
generate a PNG files. And this
PNG files generated at runtime
is a feat affair to the
incremental DMD and can then you
can do the online phase in IR,
rock station or laptop. So of
course, I'm in this full artist
simulation, take ours. And of
course, the name, the
reconstruction takes seconds,
everybody knows that. But most
of the tools we're going to be
using here comes from the
exascale computing project from
the doe. And that particular you
can find this in the alpine CFP,
which is one of the projects.
So, we're going to have we
basically are going to discuss
here, what's gonna happen if we
do data compression, and how we
merge the instead of
visualization with incremental
DMD with gun as we're gonna see,
we blurry, mix it up, somehow,
the offline and online phase of
this, there's four of the DMD
workflow. Okay, just to make a
point. This is the vanilla the
MDR grid, there's axiom Daragh
written, you're not in lib Ron,
you have this is just to make a
point that, we're always going
to be using a randomizer. That's
in SVD. And incremental SVD.
Okay. But one of the things that
we have to take care of is, when
you do large scale simulation,
there is not shots comes from
those parallel computations.
They are distributed in the file
system. As you can see, here,
this is a nice picture, show you
the meters partition for our 16
processor for you know, some of
the analysis we did in for CFD
many years ago, is a Lazada
class submarine mesh. We use
this mesh for many, for many,
you know, CFD competitions in
the past, but my point here is
that the special care should be
given to the subdomain interface
data, you're there to arrange
does not check the snapshots.
Why is that? So? Because
partition for computing SVD,
which is basically a dense
matrix is not exactly the same.
partition that when you do, I
mean, there's snapshots that
come in download to disk from a
parallel simulation. Okay, so we
have to take care of this.
Right. Now, let's get back to
spend a bit of time doing
talking about compressing
floating point numbers. Well,
several state of the art in
lossy and lossless scientific
data compressor have been
evaluated. Recently since the
desirable paper here, called SDR
bench is bench they propose a
benchmark for scientific data
reduction for lossy compressors.
There's in this paper it can
find many and we selected zfp
which is one that operators on a
three dimensional array. by
partitioning this array into
blocks of four to the power
devalues. Each blocks is
compressing the complex entirely
independently from all other
blocks.
Well, when you use zfp, you can
control the blocks quality and
compressive size by modifying
four parameters, I will not go
into the details of this
parameters. But at a high level
zfp provides five predefined
compression modes that affect
these parameters, expert fixed
rates, fixed procedure and fixer
curious and reversible. The
first four modes is a lower high
compressor razor with
controllable loss of accuracy.
And the wildly last one performs
loss of s contraction. Why is
the f3 we use the FB? Well,
because there is a strong
mathematical background, there's
a paper discussing error
analysis for the FB that you can
see here in this yellow box has
been published in the same genre
for scientific computing a few
years ago. And that's why we
adopted CFP. So, in more than
that, we adopt the sticks that
are tourismo that given a
tolerance that we select Set
minutes per meter to this
expression floor flock to the
tolerance which means in
practice that for incompressible
floating point F in a
reconstructive valid G the
absolute difference of f and g
is at most two to the power Min
X. Also what is interesting is
now zfp is available as for
compression decompression
floating points on AGF five
files format using this plugin
here. So it's easy to use.
Right? Well, let's see what's
going to happens. I come back to
this problem that we are
analyzing a few years ago is a
particle driven graph the flow
and the lock is change. Here you
have water with sediment here's
clean water is basically a
couple incompressible navier
stokes equation with sediment
transport at Grashof pentyl,
Paris six summit number one,
which means the flow is driven
by turbulence at well, you can
get the details for the day for
the initial condition and
boundary conditions in our
paper. But I'm just making a
point here that at the bottom,
you have this boundary condition
for sediment concentration,
which means that sediments are
allowed to live the domain we
assume the Boussinesq hypothesis
valid particular particles have
a heavy in the heavy fluid have
a negligible inertia and much
more more smaller than the
scales balancing just for the
mouse motion. We settled setting
the last 2.2 Is the trial inner
hexahedral mesh mesh with great
grid spacing point 035. We're
using the residual base
variation multiscale finite
element formulation for the
fluid and streamline upwind
Petrov Galerkin finite element
formulation for sediment
transport, and we record 1000
snapshots. The full word a model
is a live mesh parallel
simulation, we spend roughly 80%
of the time when the solvers are
less than point 1% for output
writing, half point percent of
total time for paravur catalysts
and 18% for the remainder of the
task. And we use measure EO for
mapping DMD approximation and
modes to the original notes, not
of coordinates. This is a
snapshot of the simulation, but
you can see the formation of the
Kelvin Helmholtz billows. Okay.
Yeah, so snapshot complex on
this table here. So the storage
requirement for the quantities
of interest in compression rates
for the simulations. You can see
for the raw data for the zfp
with lossless compression, and
ZF we'll fix the Rikyu was for
two tolerances one more tight
and on more relaxing and and we
are recording we were storing
the raw the three velocity
components UV w the pressure the
sediment concentration and
sediment deposition, you see
that as far as some of those
variables, we achieve high rates
of compression, you know, the
sediment concentration and the
deposition in they're all
compatible with the people
recorded in the benchmark I
mentioned before. So, this is
more or less what people have
seen in those datasets. What
remains to be seen now is when
we do this, of course, we're
gonna save a lot of disk, but
how this will influence DMD and
reconstructions. Okay. So, we do
the reconstruction, this plot
here in your left show you the
big sign noise ratio, which is a
measure of how good are your
compressors in blue zfp lossless
PS and are in decibels around
more than 100 which is very good
zfp with accuracy a fixer
creates the tendon power minus
six is over 75 With considering
Excellent. And for, you know,
keeping three, keep in three or
four digits is not that good,
but is acceptable. And the right
you see the influence of
compression on the symbol of
ballots, well, the dashed line
represents, you know, the base
of the 250 similar values that
are going to be selected for the
DMD reconstruction, we see a
deviation, similar values for
when we do you know, when we are
when we do a very aggressive,
lossy compression, and but the
single the singular values agree
with it, you see, lossless and
no compression are on top of
each other, and we do a less
aggressive, we have a very good
match until let's say 350. So
we're gonna do, we're gonna see
what happens when we do with
reconstruction with 250 You
know, a single foot with the
bases built with 250 melts, or
Okay, oops, all right. But
before that, let's see what
happens with the DMD Eigen value
analysis for the loss
compression for 10 minus six,
you see that all the apparently
all the Eigen values are okay,
we have some small
discrepancies, and we when we do
zoom in in this box, but
however, for the more aggressive
compression, we see more
discrepancy in the Eigen values
and of course, we will, it will
affect the empty
reconstructions. So, in this
table here, you see the forbade
news nor relative error between
the approximate and unreasonable
snapshots for this problem,
consider a basis of 250 you see
the Frobenius norm, okay, more
or less, when we do no
compression or lossless
compression or this 10 to the
minus six security, they're more
or less of the same order, but
they are twice as big, when we
do a more more aggressive
compression. This picture on
right see, you can see the
absolute error between the DMD
reconstruction with a basis of
250 50. With a basis using 250
eigenvector from the lossy
compressing data with 10 to
power six minus six compression
and there is no snapshot for
segment that kind of situation
at this time. So you see very is
more absolute error, but this is
not enough. Let's see more
measure other measures. In the
graph in your left you'll see
the relative error in time
measured as the difference
between the reconstructed
solution and the end solution.
You see them the norms and see
that this zero is very, you
know, when you do no
compression, in in in orange
lossless compression you In
green lossy with the 10 to the
minus $6. And the more
aggressive compression, we see a
very good error. The lossy and
lossless are more or less on top
of each other until that time
and there are certain different
diversions afterwards words, and
but it overrode their errors is
still low below them to the
minus two. And right you see the
time history of the relative
seven mass error for all cases
they are very good. And when you
do very aggressive, lossy
compression decompression, you
see that there are some
oscillations, but overall
the mess is very well
reconstructs. Finally, well a
minute people who do this
simulations, there are some
quantities of interest global
conflicts of interest that they
always look. One is the front
position over time. And for
this, which is basically how you
compute how rare is the front
over time, you can see there's a
very good match, no matter of
what you do, using raw data, for
the for the model raw data from
the simulation, and all the
compressor compressing all the
snapshots, you see, for this
global constant interest, you're
on top. And also from the
sediment mess time history,
that's, you see the same thing.
So I mean, it appears that
compressing snapshots by using a
some with keeping some accuracy,
good balance between you know
how much you're gonna compress?
And decompress is is a good
idea, by the way that the
decompress time for the MD is
negligible. Okay. All right. So,
let's see, what happens when we
have snapshots coming for an
adaptive mesh refinement and
coursing. Well, when when you do
adaptive mesh refinement course
simulations, the meshes we have
they have of course, a different
number of nodes and numbering in
order coordinates and it can
also lead to different mesh
topologies instructors for
instance, this is a CR three
levels of refinement and then
you see you know, I mean this
matters of course, they don't
live in the same space and you
can have something like this a
hanging node with a constraint
and by the neighbors or you can
have situation like this nashwan
and messages to that they have
they have the same number of
degrees of freedom, but
different topologies we
circumvent this issue by
considering alto projection of
the numerical simulation results
for different meshes into a
reference target mesh. So, there
are some issues here okay. The
choice of a proper method to
successfully project functions
in different finite element
space is not a trivial task in
particular, because conservation
may not be satisfied, if you go
to the literature there, there
are several walks in dressing
this issue. However, we have to
bear in mind here that mess
projects are for us in to build
you know, a dam these snapshots,
they are course as a post
processing phase after computing
the adaptive mesh refinement
cost solution. Therefore, it
cannot lead to cumulative
errors. So projection is not
doesn't accumulate error. There
is another issue here is how
much the snapshots will retain
from the regional the regional
accuracy of this adaptive mesh.
So, what we found out that we
need to choose a reference
target meshes target mesh with a
characteristic length equivalent
with the system in adaptive
meshes in order to avoid major
accuracy losses. So let's see
how it works. That solution or
the dollar mesh be given by the
suspension satisfying this LT
projection here in the proper
space. And of course l two is
defined by the target mesh and
in temporal and here you sub
project is the optimal Carolan
interpret in this L two nor from
this space. So, we compute the L
two projection is orthogonal
projectors is defined in the
following linear system. And you
this isn't going to solve this
for your project, where m is a
standard mass matrix for any
finite element code in B is a
projection matrix. Well, we've
proved the theorem in this paper
down here is that if every
degree of freedom of the
reasonable mesh is also a degree
of freedom of the resin F
reference mesh, then the matrix
B is full rank, right, which is
very tough to requirements of
the math in practice. But we
find out that having a reference
mesh representing the fine scale
is enough for practical
purposes. So, this algorithm is
a snapshot projection we work
like this have an input the
finite element solution,
considering adaptive mesh
refinement of courses in the
output data projects and
solutions. So for each
observation time step, you'll
apply them to projection and
stack the result in snapshot
maintenance or output the
projected solution to this
compressor or not compressor
doesn't matter. On the right,
you can see here's as you know,
I'm going to is a simple
exercise, we project the
solution and this is adaptive
mesh, and this is infinity norm
is one when you use this mesh
with represented finest scalar.
Here, the projection is very
good. Or if we project in a
totally unstructured mesh more
or less keeping the same scale
we have also a very good a very
good error. Right. So let's
check out how it works in
practice. Let's examine right
now, the problem of a 3d Rising
bubble which basically a capo
navier stokes equation, sorry,
just one second is a couple
navier stokes equations with a
convected level set where we
consider surface tension with a
continuous surface model. The
details are in the paper in this
yellow box here. This is the
initial condition and no slip
boundary condition apply to all
boundaries. The computation
domain is this box here we're
going to have grid size. In this
interval, there'll be 240 time
steps. This is a timestamp the
bubble radio the inside bubble
position in the properties and
we consider gravity like this.
So, first thing is how this idea
of looking at projected meshes
works. We can see here this
plots the adaptive mesh
solution, the projection for
this time step and of course
mesh in intermediate mesh in a
fine mesh projection. And in the
table here, you can see how
costly is the projection you'll
see well for fine mesh as the
projected cost is negligible and
is its projection like this out
to projection is available on
this either is not as part of a
landmass is part of Phenix. So
projection is not an issue. The
issue here is how the solution
becomes menu really do take a
look on the solution quality in
this project and matches. So,
you'll see some quantities of
interest for this problems is
the volume of the bubble, the
sphericity the rise velocity and
the center of mass for the you
know for the simulation with
adaptive mesh, and for Matt and
the output in the quote with the
course intermediate and then
find projects and of course the
course from the project the
solution project and the course
match is good for nothing, but
for the intermediate mesh and
the find one there you know this
quantities are okay, which gives
us a good indication that
projectile projectile can give
you a snapshot in the same base
in the same space. So we proceed
to do the MD reconstruction with
the projected meshes here is
basically the relative error
for the reconstructions and we
see his relative error here. And
this is the training and then
afterwards training, you see the
trainer is the arrow increases a
bit, but we have a win in all
this at the end are good. And
for the course, mesh is not that
good. But you can see in this
two slides here, that the bubble
shape at that, for the sign
during the sign reconstruction,
which is the end here of the
training and for the prediction,
within the last step is more or
less, okay, and we can see some
really oxalates are for the
coarse mesh. And, of course, in
this table here is see for
several ranks the MD
reconstructions, and then they
see the relative error. Of
course, if you increase the rank
of reconstructions, the error
diminishes. But and you have,
you see a, you know, astonishing
a very a very, very, very nice
speedups. So, it seems to be a
good idea to, to have all these
snapshots in the same space by
projecting the solutions. So
let's see how the MD performs
for the quantities of interests.
Again, I see volume sphericity,
the rise velocity and center of
mass. And I believe this is for
using the record, I'm sorry, for
using the reconstruction with 60
vectors. And you see again,
reconstruct the MD
reconstruction with a coarse
mesh is good for nothing, but
for the or for defining an
intermediate projection. They
are value, I mean, you can do it
without any problem. Okay. So
let's now see is the if how this
idea of mesh projection of
having all the snapshots in the
same space walks when we merge
this with, with data
compression. So by using only
the final protected mesh, here
is the time share is now in the
offline file phase is 90%. For
solvers, less than 1% of the
time for output writing 1% for
power of your catalyst 3.3% for
the bubble position projection
to reference mesh, and 80% for
reminder, workflow components,
but including all the stuff you
need for adaptive mesh
refinement, in coursing process
inland mesh for this specific
problem. And you can see here
you see a view of the for the
time 2.25 The adaptive mesh
match with the velocity price in
the velocity plots and the
corresponding projection of the
level set or the bubbles
position at the final mesh. Note
here that we compress both the
level set field on adaptive mesh
and the level set field on the
projected mesh. The projected
mesh contain more nodes and
elements and given that it's the
same Metro snapshots, of course,
it enabled the use of DMD all
the other fields are stored in
their original and depth meshes.
So here again, we see the table
we can see the three velocity
components and then compress it
in the compression rates, the
pressure the the level set of
this in this in adaptive mesh,
and the Lego set in a protected
mesh that will be used for the
DMD reconstructions, you'll see
that we achieved some less, we
can discuss it later, why we
achieve less than in the other
case, but still good compression
rates. Okay. And again, now we
do the same thing. This is the
big to sign noise ratio. And we
see that for zfp and lossless
compression and the same
accuracy level for zfp
compression. Here we don't see
you know, more or less the the
lossless and zfp. We're curious
10 to minus six is more or less
on top of each other and the
quality of the aggressive, more
aggressive data compression is
not that not that, you know,
they still have a good quality
this is somehow reflected manual
look at the singular values for
a basis of 20. Similar values,
we, we have exceeded all the
singular values. And I'm going
to do the reconstructions of
with 20 vectors, but they're all
more or less on top of each
other. And if we look at the
Frobenius norm, relative norm
between the approximate and
original snapshot for a basis
with 20 vectors, we see there
are more or less the same order
of magnitude. And again, the DMD
Eigen values, if you look at
them, the raw data the last less
and the to compress it in the
compressor with different
different tolerance, they're all
on top of each other more or
less reflecting what we see in
the signal of similar values.
Okay. So, this is the relative
on the left relative error in
time for the reconstruction
between the vectors, we see that
that's okay is relative error
and time is bounded then minus
two and the timing history of
the bubble mess which is which
is very, very similar with the
what began what got with no
compression at all. Right. So,
so far, we have been, you know,
seen the effects of data
compression and how to handle
snapshots with different coming
from in when they live in
different spaces. We do it by
compression. And now we're going
to see what we do when we merge
DMD with in situ visualization.
Alright, some water and do
faster here. We see, well, do we
have seen the integration
between live mesh and parallel
catalysts and this is provided
by adapter, which is implemented
when on one of the catalysts
API's more or less we couple
live mesh with Parvo catalysts
and we produce a PNG files that
will feed streaming the DMD. The
adapter invokes a Python script,
which is supported for the power
of your user interface. And the
adapter involves this processes
initialize, go process and
finalize, which are methods to
invoke pipelines defined in this
Python scripts. The data
structure for from the
simulation code is assessed in
memory I mean, in situ, and they
are mapping into adapter using
the API for purview catalysts,
and catalyst using VT gate data
model to perform the data
structure mapping. The use of
this simple we output PNG file
every X time steps, and the
right right data ever KX
timestamps with K is much more
than one and PNG file files are
ingested into the streaming TM
the algorithm which is on the
right I'm not going to do is I'm
just saying it's very similar to
the incremental SVD of finding
labor on however, it's tailored
for receiving PNG images. We use
this Python package open CV for
handle image and psychic image
for computing metrics. And the
images are converted to black
and white before processing and
pixels are Heather has no
failures in the snapshot matrix.
This is to make things simpler.
Alright. So what we do the
industry medium the underlying
block is changing computation.
We use powerful catalysts to
generate image images for us at
the midplane of the all of the
lock exchange problem. PNG files
have only this amount of pixel
width accounts for 153 megabytes
we store all our 1000 image we
we store for every time step and
this is the reconstructed for
basically 250 DMD modes k out
visually there's no difference
between any of this for the
model image that the Institute
of visualization image produced
with online with the purview
with the Florida model data and
the reconstruction with the
purview, same image with DMD
reconstructions, however, have
to bear in mind that assessing
accuracy image needs more
different metrics. Why we use
this structural similarity index
which is computed like This is
very standard, I just would like
to point out that if this is the
original image, and this is to
compressor, the compressor, the
image, the PNG, maybe you have,
you know, the same ms II. But
this metric tells you that this,
the image on the right is much
better than the middle image. So
when we handle everything as
images, they're better use this
metrics in order to assess
quality, together with our
standard metal more mathematical
error analysis. So for like a
standard problem, what we, what
we get when using the streaming
DMD, this mark here is, is the
mark that we have 250 snapshots
and, oh, they have construction
keeps going with this, there's
250 snapshots or PNG files
coming in. And you see this
metrics, as close to one is
means that Jamin images are very
good. And you see by the scale
of that says is true. The DMD
reconstructed images are very
good. And that is also reflected
in Frobenius norm in time, and
also in the relative error. They
always tell us that the
reconstruction the with this,
using the images, producing the
vibrancy to visualization,
they're, you know, they're the
reconstructions are very good.
What we got when we do the same
thing, the 3d Rising bubble
problem, well, now we generate
black and white images at the
bubble midplane PNG files have
only this. So, we have a three
megabytes for storing old 240
image and we do reconstruction
with Rs 60 and C, you see the
the power of your catalyst
image, the name the
reconstruction and so on. We see
here in the end, after the
training does mean the
prediction phase that DMD does
not do a good job in the
reconstruction but is more or
less, we knew that when we when
we observe the reconstruction,
the bubble perhaps, is because
the boundary conditions we we
apply here isn't is a no slip
boundary condition. And this is
reflected in. In, in, in the
other metrics. This is the
similarity struggle similarity
index for the record tracks and
match images from the bubble
shape is still good. And we see
a degradation here in the end.
Again, this is a you know, when
you start to have the 16
standard reconstruction, the
Frobenius norm is not that good
and but still tolerable. And the
error is growing, as we saw
before, but it's still
acceptable. Okay, and we have
five minutes. Should I continue
or stop here and go to the q&a?
I can go very quickly on this.
Basically, there's what do you
think, Tony?
Yeah, I think it's up to you. We
are pretty flexible in the
schedule,
okay. I mean, I will jump to
this because it's more
theoretical work. Suppose we
have a PD system that we have
this vector here and this is a
kind of multi compartmental
system and isn't only an
operator that defines the
interaction between an INFJ
compartments. Of course, this
place is equipped with B C's in
initial condition for each
compartment and depending on the
type of the patient we can use,
you know, the Larkin Petrov
Galerkin, a variation load scale
for spatial discretization. The
question here is what we do
within with MD reconstruction,
it is the will freedom or each
compartment separately or stack
of them like this and do the DMD
for the copying approach. Of
course, this will demand more
memory. But of course, in the
reconstruction follow this
fraction, but see which one is
is better. Right. In this paper
below. We have a mathematical
analysis. And we have three we
have proved three theorems.
First one is for a compartmental
dynamic systems such that we
have this conservation, the
exact same the reconstruction
utility here also, you know is
conservative. The second theorem
says that for problems with some
subset of a compartment
satisfies the hypothesis of
theorem want it to remain
theorem one also holds for the
DMD reconstruction in this
subset. The third theorem says
that for a compartmental problem
with satisfy the hypothesis of
theorem one, we have
additionally, that this is, you
know, this condition here that
the compartments are, are
positive or zero and the MD
reconstructions are also this
positive or zero at all
positions in time, then we have
the L one arrow is bounded for
all type some remarks on this
theorems, there is no negativity
hypothesis on your tilde 14
Three, it's hard to say that
this holds in general, and this
quantities be may become
negative. But what we've seen
practice that this assumption
remains satisfied for many
problems, at least, for a model
a period of time after the end
of the training periods. In such
a regime to train, we may
suspect that there are bound
given by two and three to help
preventing the blow up the era.
Moreover, if one was to perform
them the ornamented variable
space, let's say we have one we
used to this two compartment and
unknown in a combination of
those. We would suspect that
this conservation will hold in
the DNA reconstruction despite
the presence of the nonlinear
variable. The mathematical
details is already paper, I will
skip this, but let's see how it
works. This is a system if we
actually diffuser equations,
which basically is a special
temporal domain. suggestible In
fact, it's recovered and this is
a population for simulating
spreading of disease. So, as I
said before, as a standard for
the susceptible compartment II
for infected are for the cover,
and then the for disease, the
sum the sum of all compartment
with the Center of Disease
population is represented by the
population, the total number of
leading people, the better as
the transmission rate gammas are
the symptom symptom African
recovery rates, delta is the
mortality rate. And here is that
our distribution tensors of the
different population groups, and
the signal incorporated the lag
effect presenting between the
time of faction in developed
symptoms, and the model six, you
know, and in six to model the
delay of seven in practice, when
new restriction of other
measures are introduced in the
details of the model is in the
paper in the yellow box in below
in the slide. Alright, the model
walks. This is in in in pink,
you see the symbol in this the
number of the season population
against what was measured in
state of Georgia in the US. And
we observe an accent that women
for the total population for
Georgia for this model, and this
is the evolution of the impacted
infected compartment i for the
GA simulation of different
phases of the epidemic. They
weren't they one month, four
months, and they weren't 150. Of
course, the outbreak is more was
more severe around the Atlanta
area, but we have other hotspots
as well. Well how DVD performs
on this. Well, we're gonna see
that the variation of the you
know, the, the mass has to be
conservative. And we see that if
we do the MD reconstruction in a
couple uncoupled way. We see we
don't see any conservation. But
however, if we do the request
DMD reconstruction with a couple
way, we see a very good
conservation even beyond the
training periods. And this is
the infected compartment, you
know, five days after the end of
the training periods, and we
have a very good agreement
between the four model and then
the request functional for the
couple using the couple way of
doing this okay in this is the
error analysis and for the GA
simulation This is the how we
compute the error and for the
different compartment is
susceptible infected recovered
indices, we see that a couple of
them the reconstruction fail for
several compartment giving an a
set of results in contrast, the
couple DMD formulation you know,
reconstructed the dynamics even
after training and provides
reasonable stipulation for three
week inter interval which is
very good for the problems of
you know, epidemic precision and
it more or less confirms what
the mathematic mathematical
analysis have you know,
predicted for us. So, final
remarks and discussion to end
and then and finally go to the
q&a some more water before I
started my final remarks Okay,
we have seen that lossy
compression diminish the
snapshot persistent storage
requirements and contributors to
decrease IO Diem the
approximations used to
decompress the data may lose
accuracy, depending on the
singular value stress hold. If
lost data compression changes
the singular values before the
educational level. Jim the
eigenvalues may tend to and I'm
gonna SPECT not a good
reconstruction. We have observed
that decompressing the snapshot
does not increase computational
effort during the in the
approximation. One thing I it's
I'm pretty sure data compression
is here to stay you guys in the
labs are putting in a lot of
effort on doing this in
compressing compressing
scientific data set. So is there
in please use it there are other
options in XFP that remains to
be explored. I'm not claiming
that we did the best job we just
said okay. Look data compression
here is good, but we have to you
know, do more computations in
Splore more now, of course,
there are other scientists data
compression work taking a look
like SZ M God plus etc. And one
thing that is important for you
guys in the liberal community is
I believe that any method based
on snapshot can benefit from
data compression is more or less
obvious this thing but we I
never see many people use
scientific floating point
compression in in in this method
and we could SPECT more savings
for our Lupron computations. You
see, when you do of course, if
you do parametric parametric
studies that were generated much
more data. Well, when you do
more compression, you do more
more saving. So, you know, I
mean, by compromise using
floating point in compressions
for parametric studies can
expect much more savings. Again,
I mean, using image data for DMD
approximation presents accurate
results considering the
presented metrics, with notable
stars reduction with promoting
simple data transfer.
Another thing is, projections of
fix a match could not the best
could not be the best way of
dealing dealing with a snapshot
when in different spaces. But
it's simple. Why? While l two
projectors is embedded in many
existing codes, open source
codes like live mesh Phenix and
I believe in many of the
simulation codes available that
do we we have this projection
already implemented. Our
experience shows that the hint
is if possible, select the fifth
fixed mesh containing
approximately the smaller scales
obtaining in your adaptive mesh
refinement of course and
solution. Well, I mean,
institutionalisation turns the
offline in online phases blurry.
They are somehow have mixed it
together. If it's possible to
generate incentivization image,
target to the problem is q you
cue points of interest, short
time incremental DMD prediction
can a the steering task that's
runtime. You see, if you're if
we're receiving a bunch of
images and then doing a DMD or
some run record correction, you
can somehow predicted at runtime
God is going to happen with your
simulation and then take action
using it You know, uses
different capabilities built in,
in your simulation coats. Again,
I think that image metrics
should complement our
traditional error analysis.
Look, we are using, you're using
images right now. So you have to
take a look on Image Metrics in
the end, for compartmental PDE.
S, we have seen that our theory
and have been you know, in
America experiments have shown
that a couple DMD should be
preferred. Yeah, that's the
thing myself, and the sun
reality our colleague, Amanda
matassa. From he did from
computer science, he helped She
helped us a lot on the steering
part like Patrick about the
race, Alex viguerie, which now
at cdc monographie, my former
students as they come out, also
my former students, during the
course as my former students,
Gabrielle bajos, who did a lot
of works. In the end, he's
finished his PhD right now. But
a machine learning company in
Brazil already hired the guy.
And Victor Silva and Reynolds
soza also helped us a lot.
Victor Silva now is at Apple.
And the Reynolds soza Is your
colleague in Oak Ridge, you can
talk to him about this steering
stuff that he knows a lot about
this. This is our, you know, I
would like to acknowledge our
supporters. And that's it. Thank
you so much. Nice to be here
with me today. And thanks for
your attention. I'm ready for
q&a.
Yeah, thanks for that wonderful
talk. Yeah, I'm particularly
impressed by the comprehensive
workflow on like, different
simulations, different
applications. And like the
interesting error analysis, I
read an analysis on the data
compression. So let me see, I
don't think we have a question
in the chat room yet. So
probably, I can kick off with
one question. So I'm curious
about like, what do you do? What
I mean, what do you think about
like incremental TMD? In the
parametric case, like we have? I
know, you do the Sacramento
transport as an example, I think
you have one particular workshop
number and Smith number, right.
So yeah. So if we have like,
multiple of them, maybe we can
do it in like simultaneously and
rebuild the incremental SVD
simultaneous Li. So do you think
like, you will have giving a new
testing parameters, another
unseen problem in the in terms
of the pressure, and there's
some problem? So how would you
like to the DMD prediction
there?
That's a very good question. You
see, I think there is a strong
potential. If you figure out the
problem with this data
visualizations, figure out, you
know, this the script in order
to produce the images, right? If
you have a permit, and let's
suppose that you do informatics
exploration, and we have a lot
of jobs running in a
supercomputer. And for each one
of them, you are downloading,
you know, for the same point of
view, more or less with same
mesh, your download images, I
can think I can think that you
can do, you can show that
there's a database of images and
doing incremental DMD, we can
show a new parameter and see if
the reconstruction is okay. I
think this is a test we're
doing. worth doing. Because
you're going to check out in
runtime, what it what we're
going to happen in this new
parameter, and figure out if we
have to start a new simulation.
I mean, yes, not good. Is the
indication for you. Okay,
thanks. But more than that,
let's, let's feel let's start
simulation with the new
premiers, right. Clear
application of this idea? I see.
Yeah, our group was more and
more we were worried at that
time, in order to complement
what we have been doing in the
steering in order to you know,
in doing the streaming DMD to
predict what's going to happen,
and then intervene, intervene in
the code. But what you have said
is really I do agree with you,
if you have if you figure out
for, let's say, the same
configuration and several
parameters, and you have the
images, you can just suppose
you're streaming dem data, this
new parameter and see if it's
worthwhile to increase your
parameter space or not. Yeah.
Yeah,
That's right, I think we can
talk more on this merit. Because
the lib rom team, we, we are
also looking at like, having
automatic like error indicators
for like finding the parameters
that we have to like build more
snapshots for like having a
better universal estimation in
the whole parametric domain. So,
yeah, maybe we'll learn from
your experience. And maybe we
can also talk about our work in
the residuals riffin. Like
sampling methods there.
Yeah. Tell me that's, that's
absolutely right. I mean, you
could use for instance, KNN, or
any other data to combine all
these things, or near your
neural network to you know, I
mean, to do this, but as
absolutely correct. I think your
your team is, you need to do
that. It's worth doing.
Yeah. So I may ask one more
question. So. So it is like, I
don't have a clear idea about
this. But you, I mean, in the
hotel, we mainly record and
talking about this simulations,
but so I'm thinking about like,
a data or decision making
process or like multi Curie
problems. So usually want to
match the simulation with some
kind of observed data. And there
are some noise in there. So do
you have like, any comments on
some insights on how the noise
level? Is? I mean, related or
affecting the, like, the zfp
compression level that you
should choose in the DMD?
That's a very good question.
See, ya. Yeah, those things?
Yeah. Big sign of the noise
reason, is, is a measure of what
the guys who wrote this, this
paper I quoted here, were.
Yeah, those guys, no, no, those
guys here for the benchmark,
they tested. And they, they,
there is a, a, let's say, I
mentioned, they, they propose a
benchmark with all this
compressor. And this, those
guys, they are one of the
apprentices that is new to our
community, at least we don't
tell much about this is this big
sign noise ratio, and tells you
how this noise generated by the
compression effect. So your,
your, your snapshots, in the
end, when you decompress? How is
that how your snapshots will be
affected. So I mean, compressing
and decompressing by something
like, you know, 75 to add, or
is, is considered good. This
come from from from those image
guys. You see, when we're doing
this, we went to the image
literature. If you take a look
on the on the paper where we did
that, we we quote, image book,
this is something new for us ces
sassy, guys, but it's bread and
butter for for the image guys.
So I'm saying that that's why I
said in the end, there's more on
data compression. And and that's
why we choose zfp In the
beginning, because there is this
strong mathematical background
and error analysis for zfp as
well as for the other.
Compressor is one.
M guard Plus, there's a strong
mathematical background in this
M guard plus, so it's warm. I
mean, it's hard to say at that
point, which one is the best
one. But again, I I I repeat
what I wrote here, data flow
compression here is here to
stay. So is this something that
our community has to start
coping but in our experiments
says just say to us that oh,
okay, it's it's not that bad. We
can cope with this because we
can Wanna restart receiving data
there? They're only available in
in the compressor for Yeah,
these are too big.
Yeah, I totally agree like
expressor is interesting. Like
the zfp they are actively
researched in within the cost of
era now, and we'll probably
certainly want to, like
incorporate these techniques in
the lib ROM that we are
developing to, like,
they are for instance, as Yfp is
part of the HD F five, there's a
plugin for this. And I'm pretty
sure that your guys in the labs,
don't just go for the exascale
problem project guys and talk to
them there. They will be readily
available.
Yes. Okay. Yeah, so let me ask
once more, are there any more
questions from the audience? So
if there are no more questions,
let's thank ever again for
sharing his excellent research
with us. Okay, you